tout d'abord, cela commence avec Terry Malik
sa réputation dans l'industrie ce qu'il a
fait avec ses films et ses acteurs et
fondamentalement tous ceux qui apprécient son
travail veulent travailler avec lui les gens sont
juste attirés par lui nous développions
autre chose avec lui et que nous '
Je travaille depuis quelques années
et cela est arrivé et il nous a invités
à aider à produire et un autre acteur a été
impliqué et et il s'est senti dehors et j'ai dit
que diable allons lancer le casting de la
mère était un défi parce qu'elle
devait être  quelqu'un qui exsudait juste l'amour et
jessica chastain elle est tellement naturelle
et si belle elle incarnait tout ce
que nous imaginions de la mère
elle est vraiment engagée et elle-même
a cette élégance que vous ne pouvez pas atteindre à
moins que vous ne soyez né avec elle quand j'ai d'abord
rencontré Brad c'était juste avant que nous ne fassions la
section de séduction du film, donc Brad
et moi sommes derrière vraiment hé ravi de
vous rencontrer qui tout d'un coup étaient sur l'
herbe et vous savez que nous sommes un peu comme
jouer à l'esprit  h les cheveux l'un de l'autre et il
était incroyablement gentil et drôle et
charmant et intelligent et juste un
gars vraiment génial et puis la prochaine fois que je travaille
ensemble, nous sautons directement dans le
mariage et avec les enfants et il est
vraiment allé pour les scènes effrayantes difficiles
l'une des premières choses que Harry
m'a dites est qu'il n'a jamais voulu un marteau
et une pince à une scène à la façon dont elle est écrite et
il ne ferait que quelques prises et
il torpillerait toujours la scène et
ce que je veux dire par là si Jessica et moi
nous nous disputons nous nous battons l'un contre l'autre
on fait ça et la deuxième prise du coup
on l'a envoyé en thaï le plus jeune et
devient soudain autre chose et il
voulait juste créer ce chaos pour trouver des
moments de vérité le casting des
trois  garçons était immédiatement ce que j'ai
identifié comme l'un des plus grands
défis de la préparation de ce film, cette
réalisation a été le début d'une recherche de
deux ans à travers le Texas qui a
impliqué plus de 10 000 auditions et les
trois garçons que nous avons trouvés incluent un  cravate
Sheridan Laramie Epler et Hunter
McCracken qui joue Jack le héros de l'
histoire ouais tu sais je pense à lui
tous les jours ou je ne devrais pas dire ce que
j'ai fait et je suis désolé Shawn joue le rôle
de Jack plus âgé et il y avait un  une grande partie
du casting de son enfant et de la recherche d'un garçon
qui pourrait vraisemblablement être vous connaissez Sean
et possède sa nature d'enfant qui
était un énorme défi, les enfants n'ont
même pas lu le script là-bas leur
dirait juste avant un peu
sur ce que le  scènes sur et nous
partons Jessica et Brad
aimaient tous les deux tous les garçons et je
pense que les garçons ont apprécié la routine en
fait que c'était en quelque sorte familier
chaque jour
cette personne jouait leur
inspiration de père jouait leur mère et
ils étaient  tous deux très cohérents dans leurs
personnages respectifs et ça a vraiment
marché était très affectueux tu sais j'avais du
jaune je veux que les gens réagissent très
fortement très émotionnellement à la beauté
et à la poésie et au pouvoir des
idées  derrière ce film, il a donc été
remarquablement facile de réunir le casting le plus incroyable que
je puisse imaginer et c'est
parce que la confiance que les gens avaient en Terry
, nous savions que Tereus était un grand artiste
et nous allons créer une œuvre à laquelle nous
nous rapporterons tous et  être élevé par
vous